حدثنا عن سير المعارك في خانيونس
تحديدا في خانيونس الوضع الاشتباكات ما
تزال ضاريه جدا واصوات الاشتباكات تسمع
بشكل واضح ولافت وكما يبدو فان القصف
المدفعي العنيف والمكثف واضح انه ياتي
كواحد من اثار وتداعيات هذه الاشتباكات
المندل في اكثر من مكان في مناطق مختلفه
من من اجزاء شرقيه ل لمحافظه خانيونس ولكن
ايضا في الاحياء الشرقيه لمدينه خان يونس
تشهد هي الاخرى اشتباكات مندل بين
المقاومين الفلسطينيين وقوات الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي المقاومه الفلسطينيه تعتمد
تكتيكات محدده من قبيل تحقيق عنصر
المفاجاه الخروج ومفاجاه الدبابات
الاسرائيليه والاليات الاسرائيليه وايضا
القوات الخاصه التي تتمركز في بعض المناطق
بشكل اساسي و تفاجئها باستهدافها بالقذائف
المضاده للدروع او بعض القذائف ايضا وبعض
القنابل تفجير بعض العبوات ايضا وايضا
محاوله ربما تنفيذ عمليات في خلف نقطه
الصفر بمعنى خلف الخطوط من قبيل ما ما عرض
في بعض الفيديوهات التي نشرتها كتائب
القسام يوم امس على سبيل المثال وهي
محاوله الوصول الى ثكنات جنود في نقاط
متقدمه ومحاوله اختطاف جنود بعد الاجهاز
عليهم من نقطه صفر وهذه ربما تكتيكات
اعتمدت من قبل المقاومه الفلسطينيه في
اكثر من مكان لكن بما ان منطقه خانيونس هي
المنطقه الاكثر اشتعالا على صعيد
الاشتباكات في هذه الاونه باعتبار ان
العمليه العسكريه البريه ربما ذروتها تبلغ
في هذه المنطقه على اعتبار ان قوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي اعلنت انه ما زال
بجعبته كثير من الاهداف لتحققها لتحققها
في هذه المحافظه لكن المقاومه الفلسطينيه
واضح بانها تصيب بدقه بعض الاهداف ولذلك
الخسائر حتى الخسائر التي يعلن عنها جيش
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي هي خسائر كبيره
وكبيره جدا في هذه المنطقه وايضا في مناطق
مثل شرق مدينه غزه حي الشجاعيه مناطق من
حي الزيتون مناطق شمال قطاع غزه ايضا كل
هذه المناطق هي مناطق مشتعله ومسرح
للاشتباكات بين المقاومه الفلسطينيه وقوات
الاحتلال الاسرائيلي شكرا لك وائل الدحدوح
مراسل الجزيره كنت معنا من خان يونس